hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today i'm going to be showing you
some dot
exe games now exe games are
corrupted versions of some of your
favorite games
they may be wacky wild but usually
yeah usually they involve with taking
your soul in some way
and the first one that we're going to be
playing is called truelab.exe
so let's get started oh and by the way
this one
is an undertale.exe game which just
means that it's
a normal undertale except that the game
file got corrupted
in one way or another i can't go that
way
i don't know why i'm shrouded in
darkness
[Music]
gotta go into the lab oh
hi hello how are you doing
why do you know my name that's good it
doesn't work
well i don't know why i assumed it would
trash
junk ramen you found a red flower
oh it's behind my head don't worry i'll
keep it covered i'll protect you from
its evil
or something like that oh no there's
blood it contains blue salmon
great probably a reference to undertale
that i don't quite remember
hello is anybody in here you shouldn't
be here mark
well you know [ __ ] on me for wanting to
wander around the lab
i just
[Music]
all right well what have you got here
for me
ooh blood that's always a comforting
sight i'm sure that the next thing i see
will be wonderful and full of sunshine
and rainbows can i read these
it doesn't work well i'm guessing that
they all don't work
oh hi oh oh no oh no
oh no there's a note besides the corpse
it reads
i'm so sorry i didn't mean to turn them
into these things
okay glad we covered that
goodbye oh more blood
great i was hoping i was wishing upon a
star
i can't wait to see where this one's
gonna look
i saw that where is this
oh it's a bonanza of blood
okay it's locked yeah that's the uh
it has red bull i don't remember that
from the original game
but that's where i was supposed to
unlock to go towards the end of the game
i
suppose
hi it is a distress signal
oh i've got some stress can i signal
that to you it reads
my face is melting all right seems like
your problems might be more considerable
than mine
please end the pain anyone
[Music]
i don't think i can help i don't think i
i would love to help but i just don't
think i can
i'm just a kid after all what am i what
am i supposed to do
hi is that blood or something else
probably so i'm just going to assume
that it's something
else oh what's down here i wonder
ah there's no there's no way there's no
way back
oh boy okay all right okay what do you
got for who's
in here hey it's okay
all right don't be shy i ain't shy
who hi oh okay he's more scared of me
than i am of him
oh what a cutie i'm sure
that oh he's gone oh he's just he's just
gone
okay [ __ ] you please kill me
all right well no mercy this time it's
gonna be the
genocide route oh i need death okay
well did my best didn't work huh
all right well doesn't seem to be
working
and i'm trying you know i'm really
giving him my whompest i
i didn't eat my protein this morning i
don't have muscle mass
i can't i haven't oh i've got
no i'm level one like i can't do [ __ ]
huh
i'm trying my damns man okay all right
here comes the fist to [ __ ]
here we go ready
no oh boy
all right cool yeah that's oh i'm crying
blood now or
black ooze great what else was i
expecting in my life
hmm did i unlock something um no
not yet anyway i wonder what
oh it worked i didn't i didn't actually
expect that to work okay
well not crying oohs anymore
oh no
that's a good visual hi how's it going
all right good good good oh good talk
good talk
yeah i don't know what the dealio is
oh the head's gone
hmm that's strange and
bizarre and possibly bad can i can i go
home
can i go home uh oh well
wait wait
a little concerned where
where'd the body go okay well oh
boy okay body's just up and gone
great okay all right that's a thing i'm
sure
that it's gonna be fine
it's fine
just fine i'll go in here now
i suppose oh boy
where am i now i'm in the realm of
darkness
all i see is nothing like the empty void
of my soul
there's nothing in here
what was that i wonder
oh hi hello well welcome to the blue oh
my face
my face don't look so good on my face oh
my
oh my face don't look so good okay could
you stop chomping on my
nibbly bits all right well this is just
rude
i don't like that what are you gonna do
why didn't you quit well you know i now
that i think about it i don't
rightly know oh oh
oh ah okay all right well oh
great great we're looking at this now
great wonderful
the game closed okay well i guess we're
just left
there you go okay all right well that's
that
then okay so this next game is called
dare dot exe this game is not for the
faint of heart
user discretion is advised well
i was never really a smart one so i'll
dive
head person into danger instructions
will be given through pre-recorded voice
cues please enable audio
[Music]
okay great great lovely i love it here
we go
this is level one it is an endless game
collect 10 gems to unlock level 2.
good luck okay
whoa did you listen to the instructions
yes i i sure did boss
welp all right oh it's oh it is
different
fancy is this part too hard i mean
oh kinda it's a little difficult
you know you know how it oh well all
right
well seem to be dying a lot all right
i got it okay well oh boy
[Music]
oh you've unlocked level two
yay
the instructions are unknown
that that didn't help anybody
oh okay all right
[Music]
i can do blue jump that is awfully
convenient this seems easy
come on
what what but i was i
hey whoa hi
[Music]
okay okay here we go we're gonna have a
lot of final oh she is coming for you
she is not deleted she is here
she wants to be free set her free
set her free set her free
focus okay
is this like a doki doki literature
club.exe game
is that what this is whoa
okay well please stop
well you know i can't stop from uh i'm
gonna do not go any further well here i
go not listening to
you here we go oh
boobs mackenzie is that you oh okay
don't touch that that is
that is a no-no toucho all right you do
that
whatever that is you do that
wait oh it's oh i'm sorry
oh oh why is the pause but no okay well
i'm
just gonna continue our gas all right
all right well i'm just gonna keep
running then
okay
miney my name is kara gentner i need to
see my senpai again set me free
are you a yandere oh it's called
dare dot exe d-e-r-e
is in yandere it's called deray
uh-oh oh do not [ __ ] bro i can't
wait do not collect 20
oh no no i don't know what he wants
oh stop please i am okay it's quite
challenging i
it's it's shockingly surprisingly
challenging oh good thing i'm so skilled
and good at games
here we go all right
i made some modifications okay
oh oh
i don't know what is happening holy [ __ ]
doomstones are checkpoints
sure let's go okay
all right i don't know what the uh hi
okay lady fell down jump
okay goodbye oh what was
that oh my taint
oh excuse me oh sorry oh
no i oh you reversed it right after i
get to the checkpoint you sack of tit
oh got it i oh but i forgot about the
whole reverse thing
it's oh hello friend okay bye
see ya oh i'm not gonna okay that's not
good
well i'm probably gonna die here jump
jump and okay we're back to normal yeah
we're back to normal
all right girl oh you're you're really
really dick-a-tree about this
ain't ya
okay hello oh that's not good okay don't
touch the lady
good duly noted oh
okay that's not good okay this isn't oh
hello ladies
how are you doing i'm assuming these are
nuns that's why i'm calling them ladies
oh hello all right whoa bouncy balls
oh bouncy balls oh no
oh
yeah made it okay what is this i don't
like it i don't like it
oh hi you're you're you're a what oh
your
chain your dangly chain okay don okay
i should have moved faster no no no
no no no no i yes okay
i'll go up seems like a bad
i knew up was going to be a bad choice
okay so up is a
bad choice okay
oh okay hello friend oh
are these gonna fall i don't trust them
i don't trust them
no i don't trust them
i got it okay set me free i don't know
who i'm setting free
and frankly i don't even care i don't
like
any of this and i got you right in your
knocking with my crotch
it means oh [ __ ]
incoming message okay my name is
i think i've been trying but it hasn't
been working
oh this looks wired
oh boy it's a good thing i'm so good at
the mechanics of this game now huh
oh well that's not oh boy
lucky lucky lucky lucky me
that's not good whoa you have to find
cara and stop her
she might destroy another city again i
know the truth oh
my balls okay all right
we made it def note she must be oh
whoa deleted let us save the world ah no
it's the same thing
i don't know i thought it would be any
different okay whoa
all right well i don't know what
okay well nice turds okay i gotta roll
them
i gotta boosh them let's boosh you get
out
my balls no boosh i boost you this way
oh nope come here you oh yes oh yes oh
oh oh why oh i made it
oh this is so precise i don't like it
i don't it's like a goddamn
oh oh i made it
behind you i don't want to look i'm not
looking i
don't want to look i'm making it
oh me too ah me too lady
made it okay so far so good set me free
am i supposed to land on that oh [ __ ]
hell
ah okay ah i set you free i get it
almost got me oh oh that that eye
okay thank you
i think i think i'm gonna thank you for
that there's gonna be something up here
isn't there
ah none okay we wow
can't believe oh it just keeps going
this is
whoa oh my god
oh you're welcome i think
i don't know what's going on here i
don't understand any of this
it's so ver from the same point
how no yes i nailed it i am in trouble
i hate you i hate everything about
you oh why
would cara change the game like this
things were
things were so much more
it's so hard oh it's so hard oh my god
no you think ah okay
no lady lady what are you doing ladies
ladies oh okay ladies
i don't want to mess with you
i can go over two of you okay all right
we did it
we did it oh my god how much more do you
want from me cara
please cara please uh oh that looks
smack oh boy
oh it seems that since cara arrived she
made the
game easier i wonder why perhaps the
easier escape finder
i don't know why i have
oh both of us have to survive that's
that's not right yes no no
i had it oh i had it okay oh you're dead
and now
uh that no you're
oh it's oh it's useless okay good good
good
this is where freedom is a way out of
the game here let's be
heading this way i don't know okay
oh i broke through the layer oh
i didn't know i took
[Music]
no don't
don't do it
okay
little me why do i deserve all this why
do i deserve this
why do i do this cara remember this
place
funny how you thought this was a normal
church dormitory it was so blatantly
obvious that it was something else
you were so naive then well almost as
naive as you are now
figured this would be the appropriate
place to delete you
this is where they created you a human
weapon something beyond
mk ultra okay a yandere
oh selfish aggressive psychopath
but you're not the real kara you're
merely a digital copy of her
consciousness
you're nothing me is gone because of you
you took me out of the park you
destroyed an entire city oh
you're the last yandere see i know
everything
about you i knew you were hiding in our
games
the glitch is in monument rush too the
glitches in pipeline push
pathetic you thought you could scare
players enough to take control of their
minds to set you free
you thought you'd arrive on valentine's
day didn't you
you thought i wouldn't figure out where
you were hiding naive as ever
didn't even think twice before jumping
to the way out
trapping you was child's play now you
get to pay
show yourself cara oh
[Music]
hello i'm sorry dev i just wanted to see
him again
you're too dangerous without lives of
thousands
i understand kara for what it's worth
you were pretty cool out there
you jumping you're jumping sucked but
everything else was incredible
good luck to wherever you're headed will
i be heading anywhere at all
will it hurt i don't know
oh thank you for playing dare.exe if you
liked it please visit our website
www.aptsergames.com that was
that was great that was wonderful oh
based on the last yandere visual novel i
didn't even know about that
oh that's so cool though well done
all right wow well that was dare.exe but
we've got one more.exe game for you yes
it's not over yet but the last one it's
gonna be a bit of
more of a joke than anything but i think
you'll like it warning this game
contains screamers please proceed with
caution
well ain't that just delightful oh
wait a minute is this i thought oh no
i thought this was i thought this was an
exe game it's like some oh no is it like
a five nights at freddy's game oops
okay number one to survive this
nightmare you need
press control key to turn on the
flashlight and check sonic doll two if
sonic doll is not in his place press the
space bar to play emmy's voice and
attract
sonic attention if you hear strange
sounds do not make loud noises and sit
quietly extra sounds can attract someone
else's attention
all right press tab to look around the
corner where tails plush is located
tails plush likes attention so look
around the corner more often
if you do not give them enough attention
consider that you are already dead
nani do not forget to monitor the charge
of the battery survive the sunshine
okay all right sure all right
i'm down i'm game let's do this come on
bring it
bring it on what do you got what are you
a big bubble blowing [ __ ] baby
hi do you want to play with
me yeah that's exactly what i came here
for
you read me like a book baby oh hi
okay oh that's lovely oh that's lovely
oh okay oh that's even lovelier
ah oh that's good oh that's good stuff
oh help me
okay all right then wow all right hey
how are you doing
okay
all right
lesson to be learned don't press the
space bar when you're facing tails
or i'll kill you i told you this game
was gonna be a little
i told you the last one was gonna be
silly i i i
didn't i didn't undersell it did i no i
didn't at all hang on let me try this
let's try this [ __ ] here
hey where's it going all right hey how's
it going
all right
[Music]
do i just like oh
okay
all right well i guess i'm just here
till
6 a.m all right
okay okay easy enough
it's just two mechanics so i guess it
can't be that hard
maybe okay
sorry who i am yeah
we're making progress we don't have
minutes here in this wonderful world
man the longer you i stare at
i'm sorry
okay
3m i'm baby
5am hype 5 am i
help me okay we're fine apparently what
was that whole thing about making
yay sunshine we made we
made it i guess oh
hey
i'm tired the tails ask for help i feel
strange i feel the emptiness inside
something like deja vu probably because
i'm tired and not possessed by
demons okay i need to find tails
oh boy it's like it's like all over
again it's like sonic pxe
oh it is like sonic.exe all over again
what the
is it because i ate these berries
it's not sonic taking drugs i do not
think that amy gave me bad berries
i should return back before it is too
late too late i'm going for
oh i guess i should return back but i
think that amy gave me some
bad berries hello
hi hi hey hello hello
all right well
what did who is it no oh
what huh
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you
what
[Music]
okay i get is that it
is that it is that it wait mario dot
oh
wait a minute i don't know what's
happening oh
hi hello hi
so there's more to it ah all right
well anyway i'm gonna am now in there
that is delightful and everything but
i think this caps off the video pretty
well so if you want to play this for
yourself
there's more to it but thank you
everybody so much for watching these
have been super fun
exe games are their own special breed of
scary games thank you everybody again
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want to see
more.exe games more scary games
recommend them to me down in the
comments as well and you can find all
these games in the description
thank you again and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
foreign